hey what's going on is bilborough's time
for the thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I I'm
just checking in on you who how are you
um
it's Thursday November 15th and old
freckles is off the road
hey he's droppin pounds right in left
cuz he's not out there eating from his
belly he's losing his freckles sorry I'm
excited to be home with my wife and
kittens speaking of which uh last week
last Monday can you guys remember back
to November 12th
remember that trump was still president
he's still president anyways uh was I
gonna say I read a question best
friend's wife from a lady and felt that
Nia needed to chime in so what did I do
I got in touch with my wife's people to
try and see if I could poke her on the
podcast and she was nice enough to take
time out of her busy beautiful schedule
as being the greatest mother ever
welcome back to the program
Nia Hill thank you for having me oh well
what was it like to work with Tom Cruise
oh my god he is so amazing he is just so
generous so he really banged you in that
scene right oh my god it was great he
didn't let me do it no no he'd stand him
it meant he stared me in the eyes the
entire time in a real relationship after
he got the Invisalign fixed that
snaggletooth I just felt like it all
just went to another level his
commitment to the craft yeah excuse me
ma'am we're trying to do a podcast over
here I got the little white out here too
when she has her favorite show on the
one created by Harlan Williams I can't
say the name of it or she's gonna freak
out because she's kind of looking at
like why is there no sound what it's
almost the 2020s not the 1920s there
once you have some old lady playing a
piano in the corner
all right Nia I know you have a lot of
stuff to do yes we're gonna do a little
bangbang here going right into it all
right great all right best friend's wife
from best friends wave all right hello
Billy Baldwin oh yeah you like it yeah
but I win in that I like that I win yeah
that's ball than I win right
do i I don't think so all right recently
mm-hmm I'm listening
hey honey speaking to the Mikey rather
than chimed in all right yes
oh yeah all right recently I've been
posting pictures and videos on my
Instagram that are not [ __ ]
dot dot dot not [ __ ] but I wouldn't
show my parents either uh-huh period now
wait now where would you call it if you
had to rate that as a movie where is she
what do you mean like PG pg-13 are it's
not nc-17 but it's not mean it's we are
if she's showing nip and booty so then
you would say pg-13 it's pg-13 now
somebody's right yo yo yo yo give me a
boob I am 26 years old
primer yo life yeah and I've been
feeling very confident about myself Wow
babe I want to bring that back what I do
how come you guys don't dance anymore
bring what back burlesque the old
stripper song yeah Dita Von Teese does
it not in the club what do you mean in
the club in duck club da no now we're
black not again yeah and uh club no that
was never our are you going down and
I've been feeling very confident about
myself in my body I'm single with no
boyfriend or even dating
[Music]
anyways my friend sorry since I was 16
has told me that his wife has been
uncomfortable with us talking because
she's seen my pictures so they've been
friends since camp so what happens at
camp Nia stay as a camp that's right
she's told him she feels insecure and
seized my pictures even before he does
he is following here yes she's watching
you yeah he has expressed that he may
not be my friend anymore because of this
and this is not the first time I've been
blocked by male friends because their
female counterparts are social media
stalking me and claiming I'm trying to
get their man first of all nobody
stalking you you're on social media
right if you were hanging these up in
your house and you looked and she was
staring into your window no but you can
let go and just be like really looking
through someone's feed and just be like
every time they pose looking and not
only looking at the picture see who's
liking the picture and the tag like all
that kind of stuff all of that is all
out in the open I know but like you can
pay like it's just a little bit more
attention to it then unnormal just
scrolling through oh like like it's like
a little kid playing hide-and-go-seek
the first time they hide they lie down
on the floor face down and we cover
their eyes I'm hiding you're not hiding
you're putting this out for the world to
see and judge I've been told to maybe
tone it to tone down my post or not
right how I feel because the girls take
it personally and take it out on my
friends and these are these my real
friends order their girls have legit
reasons to be upset yours truly
a huge fan and love to Nia and the baby
well first of all I have to say I don't
know why you're surprised at this
reaction because you're out there
thirst-trapping-- and these girls don't
want their men to get caught in your
trap so even though you may not be
trying you break that down for the white
audience what what thirst-trapping--
she's out there thirst-trapping-- means
like you pose
photos that are intentionally like sexy
or provocative cuz you're trying to get
likes you're trying to get wow you
pretend that they're not you just oh
this is just me eating cornflakes with
most of my breastesses necessarily
acting like it's not but you know that
there's just like certain photos that
are gonna get like the reaction like I
is this is known is there any DT going
on here T's D T's dick to you it's a
kids here Oh as I imitate a vibrator I
don't know that it's a DT but it's
definitely like showing you what your
life could be yeah what you could be
throwing around the bedroom for sure so
I don't I mean it's not surprising that
they're their girlfriends and wives or
whatever are gonna be like feeling some
type of way if they're liking your
pictures so I don't know I don't think
that you're doing anything wrong but I
didn't write this I don't think that
they're necessarily wrong either but
here's the thing I feel like they were
going back to one of my earlier my
earliest appearances on the podcast the
only thing is she's been friends with
this kid since she was 16 so that's
they're fine but I also noticed in her
letter that she said that like all of
her male friends or most of her male
friends so is this another situation
where you've got a girl who's got a lot
of male friends nothing wrong male
friends involved male friends and it's
oh my god they're stalking me on
Instagram and oh my god there's such
haters and like are these men really my
friends it's like listen you just have
to understand like you have to kind of
be a grown-up about this like it's one
thing for you like I said to post
thirst-trapping-- pictures all your
girlfriends are gonna be like yeah oh my
god you're giving me life you're so hot
look at you BAM all that kind of stuff
that's what your girlfriends and like
your gay friends are for what is
thirst-trapping-- mean I just told you
what it was earlier did you yeah I said
when you're posting a picture that's
intentionally provocative or sexy to get
likes that's like a thirst trap so in
other words you're not really gonna hook
up with anybody
no sexy photo but thirsty for women late
guys are showing
tension oh that's all right sorry sorry
I'm the white cop on Sanford and Son so
I mean I'm just not surprised that
they're so what should she do did she
step away from these people
Oh I mean step away how do you have to
understand that if you start to move
into this space where you're posting
sexy photos your viewership and the way
people look at you is going to change
huge point if you're okay with that then
keep doing what you're doing but if you
have a problem with it then maybe you
want to pull back a little bit but yes
people are gonna look at you some type
of way women are gonna look at you
differently men certainly are gonna
start to look at you differently and I
don't like to certainly but go ahead
what comes with that territory is that
women are gonna be like oh I saw you
likes her photo when she was like you
know bent over being like you know yeah
yeah I actually could I could just meet
cute or whatever I don't know if I could
just insert a point here
they're both certainly good you're not
gonna insert anything welcome to both
men and women equally are gonna look at
it differently right
okay so let's not let's not turn this
into yet another that's what I said
you said women are gonna look you
differently men are certainly gonna get
you differently yeah okay so what does
that mean just say what you're saying
just don't don't yeah well okay me just
yeah I mean I stand by what I said you
think that well why can't you say that
so we can discuss it other than doing
that ah yeah well okay if Lola wasn't
here right now I would transcribe what
you just said to me which is what I
can't there's too many F words in it
that was it was like if you put a bunch
of F words into a shotgun all right well
so I women know what whether women are
doing I think you have to expect that
you know if these women are already
uncomfortable with your presence in
their man's life if you start you know
posting booty shots and all this
there kind of stuff and they see that
they're dudes liking it they're gonna be
like wow she didn't say that she was
bending over and owning that type of
stuff she just said this is some stuff
that you know it's a little more risque
but I wouldn't show my parents right
exactly meaning it's yeah like a priest
but I think you should host whatever
actually you can the Catholic if you're
feeling good about yourself and about
your body you should post all the live
long day just know that it's not gonna
be this perfect
you can just post and no one's gonna
look at you differently
I disagree fortunately unfortunately
that's just the way that it is I
disagree with that with what with that
you should go and post all these sexy
photos of yourself and put them on
social media women should not be doing
that why why are you telling women what
they should be doing with their bodies
there it is yeah and there it is from
you to tell it like I don't think women
should post it like who are you you
don't get to decide what people do with
their bodies please not say that
expression what you don't get to just
guys all so much children whatever I
want to say and her not trying to police
my words you haven't even heard what my
point is what's your point
okay my point is that I don't want to
hear it Nia you have the way you wish
the world was and the way it really is
okay okay so to go out there and and do
all of that stuff and be all provocative
and get all these people hot and
bothered there are so many freaking
cycles that's the same reason why you
don't go out there and as a celebrity
sit there in you know tree stump or
whatever the hell you call it for for a
for a candidate all you're doing is just
going out there and getting that lunatic
in the white van with the two seats that
wants to make a pipe bomb and stick it
in your mailbox you're doing stuff like
that
you're a good-looking person people are
gonna know you're good-looking like but
literally the social medias been around
so long that people aren't even
understanding that there's no
perspective on it anymore
half of these so many of these photos
that are on Instagram and all that type
of stuff those were like the kind of
photos that were in the beginning of a
magazine at a truck stop like
20 years ago and these are just regular
women up but back then you didn't know
where these women were you couldn't find
him on the Internet
there wasn't CBS taking everybody's
information and you can go on and find
everybody's address out there and you're
gonna go out there thirst-trapping-- or
whatever the hell you're calling it
showing your goods and you're just
you're playing a there's not a person in
law enforcement that would not 100%
agree with what I'm saying
this has nothing to do with a guy
telling you to do what you should be
doing with your body and has to do with
somebody looking out for your own
personal safety and that doing that is
no different than these effing morons
you see out there riding a bicycle in LA
on busy streets allegedly in this bike
lane that's not even painted and they
have their headphones on you have you
you have completely no responsibility
for your own personal safety and then
when something happens to you this is
this a hundred percent looked at that
you're a victim you are a victim but
there's nothing looking at like some
preventive measures like why would you
go on the internet and do that just post
a picture yourself smiling you're a
good-looking person and you'll attract
the kind of person you want to meet
you're gonna go out there and show your
booty crack and you're in you in you
your ass cleavage there I mean what do
you what do you what do you like you
even said that if you're gonna start
showing that everybody I was gonna look
at you differently
certainly guys now all they're gonna
think is the rude one a few right that's
all they're thinking that's the best
you're gonna get right
that is the best you're gonna get with
those photos and the worst you're gonna
get is an effing stalker right okay so
that's what I was saying I wasn't trying
to get in your world I wasn't over here
man spreading I'm just saying doing that
it's literally like becoming a comedian
posting something on the internet and
then you're gonna get upset when someone
just tears the hell out of it and says
you absolutely stink and it's just like
well you know you're not a victim here
you're the guy who posted you the person
who decided to get up on stage and
people are gonna judge you that's all
I'm saying and I think that women that
do that type of stuff
I don't think cuz they're so young I
don't think they understand the level of
F and lunatic that is out there I don't
even understand because women get it way
worse so to go out there and sit there I
mean that's like when you order the
friggin alligator farm and they're
dangling those friggin chickens over the
thing and all the Crocs go in the water
you're out of your mind well I
understand your points but I still think
that people should post what they want
to post it's there I'll just roll the
dice that you're in the herd of people
showing most of their boobs I yeah I do
because I don't think that you should be
living your life in fear of what could
happen or what might happen because if
that was the case I wouldn't leave the
house yeah I'm not talking about going
after a dream I'm talking about keeping
your ass crack in your pants
well I respectfully disagree but the
thing is the point we're gonna have a
problem when so-and-so gets to be a
certain age you don't you dare tell her
that that's gonna be okay oh wait no no
no what I know it's your daughter now
it's not okay I recognized the hypocrisy
in this but I would be like please don't
post that type of stuff on there but I
also know that I at a certain point I'm
not gonna be able to control what she
does she's not gonna be sitting here
watching what do you mean capped up what
does that mean you know beyond a certain
point I mean what what age is that what
are we talking about here when she's 18
she's an adult I'm not gonna she isn't I
think of what you thought you're you're
18 now as far as the law goes you're not
an adult
right now you're now okay Nia you were
not getting um teenage yeah you and I
get a divorce and I'm with an 18 year
old what she's an adult you're gonna be
like she's a giant oh my god I would
kill you I'd kill myself but yeah just
because I lost you know Oh God no more
romantic little enough sweet nothings I
don't know how to be romantic try not to
be romantic ooh you know what romance is
you're not you're like a generous like
sweetheart but like romantic now I
wouldn't say that you're romantic but no
I wouldn't argue with that you like
romantic things you like like a mutant
like dancing like in the middle of the
house like you like to do stuff like
that I want to take you to Frankie Valli
out here in la Marck first uh-huh yeah
oh boy can I have a Dancy boy and I have
a date mistress just just just someone
that totally plutonic just somebody that
I bring to all the stuff that I want to
go you want like a 50 year old woman why
do you gotta bring race into it cuz I
mean they'll go see Frankie Valli
come on let's me are you kidding me I
maybe my mom would go would she go I
take her
you would take my mom I wouldn't know I
love you mom
you guys would probably have a really
nice time y'all just too good to be true
you don't to see that dude he's in his
80s he still kills it right yeah that's
the guy from Jersey Boys no I never laid
a hand on you my dojo so anyway back to
the question oh my Nia's perspective my
Nia's perspective isn't that is that
you're not doing anything wrong by
thirst-trapping-- on Instagram but you
should know that that's gonna come with
a change in how you're perceived and yes
they are here's the thing if I had a
girlfriend who was hot single and she
was feeling really good about herself
and she was posting you know sexy photos
I would be one of the first ones being
like yes [ __ ] get it oh my god I mean
it what get it get your life just get
everything what is that that yes girl
show you but if Ben what do you do if I
saw that bill was liking all of her
photos I might be like now wait just a
minute
so that's just the reality of all right
let's see I finally got my ABS like I
finally I didn't have to go on the road
for you know and just ruin everything
that I got I get my ABS back and I start
I start posting shirtless photos because
I feel good about my body I would be
like yes yes yes
yeah I would but yeah and would I have a
problem with women but women already
like are looking for you and trying to
like put it out there I've seen it oh my
god that's ladies that's what my remarks
that's one of the funniest things you've
ever said just now I'm watching I've
never had that attention ever uh it's
been happening perhaps you haven't
noticed it but it happens know if it
doesn't count when you get to where I'm
at now what do you mean it doesn't count
it counts when you're nobody that means
you're good-looking all of a sudden you
start selling tickets and so I'm like
hey maybe it's like hey baby yeah yeah I
just like that doesn't mean anything
look how good she's being you like me
when I was broke I did I fell in love
with you when you were broke it was a
great time you know I got you I was
thirsty
[Laughter]
all right well agree to disagree on
those photos I mean I think you know
what people would yeah it's just like
you are in inviting like I would love
there's got to be something up there
somebody in law enforcement and stories
and all of that that the stuff that
these people are like people are
lunatics now like people were already
nuts but this like this computer with
all of this stuff that you can look at
like you couldn't do you know what I
mean like down this look back in the day
Nia if you had like a crush at somebody
on work I mean you needed your
imagination when you went home to
conjure up some sort of fit now you just
go to their Instagram page and just sit
there like an absolute voyeur it's not
even considered voyeurism anymore all
right and you just sit it's weird the
whole thing is weird and you go further
down and then their pictures aren't
enough and then you need video and then
the video my god yeah just some weird
thing the way she's like cracks an egg
when she's just showing you how to make
a overeasy egg or something and you get
all of this psycho world and then what
happens you get so into that virtual
world that if you ever asked her out and
she actually approached you you then
have a performance a problem because
it's it's too intimate because you're
used to this stuff this thing Nia is a
disease and you know I
I'm not judging anybody cuz I felt the
ramifications of it you know what I mean
trying to lay off the the the the bad
stuff on to easy so I'm just saying I
don't know you know you know me Nia I'm
liberal and I'm conservative I'm
conservative when it comes to this you
are as far as you know let's call it a
bar I get a little liberal that is what
do you what is time man like what is
2:00 a.m. do you realize that it's it's
12:00 noon in Japan right now man all
right ladies how you doing buddy you
were so good you just chilling out you
watching PJ masks PJ masks it's a PJ
masks masks yeah
can you say hi baby no no there's no
baby there say hi baby
all right this is my favorite word she
learned all week hey lo hey hey football
Wow football you say football she just
kissed the microphone can you say
football football football I love how
it's two separate words can you say
hockey football
TJ hockey yeah Hoshi what else what else
would you teach her score
all right let me I got to read some
advertising oh it's the family podcast
good girl
fill my eyes with something and let me
read some advertisement all right in
other words hold my hand all right
Oh No Papapa puppy dog no dogs that's
right you're watching in the inbox what
the hell is it all right here we go four
reads everybody hey Nene
here we go zero all right you just do
the music bed all right honey all right
all right for any smokers out there
trying to quit or if you know someone
who is there's a revolutionary way to
quit called zero zeros quit kit is a new
quilting solution proven to increase
your chances of kicking the habit by up
to four times compared to going cold
turkey in your own words
oh sorry capitalism talk about your
experience or experience of someone you
know who was trying to quit smoking ah
man I remember there was this guy and he
was trying to quit smoking but he
couldn't do it because it was too hard
and then he died no he didn't he still
lived and he eventually quit then I
think he went cold turkey I don't know
why these people want me to tell you
that anyways how many times did you /
they try before you / they were finally
successful he tried a lot a lot of times
what method already answered all is the
zero quit kilt
kit not killed is a three tiered
approach that includes prescription
medication nicotine gum and continued
support through a mobile app dare I say
this is like the Blitzkrieg
well yeah see it land Jesus I almost
forgot the last way how would you do it
well the English channels there there
a tall father hell would you do the rest
of it are you gonna get him on Lily
gonna walk across the water bring a hoop
I think it done what he did he had a
hell of a battle plan I think we would
have rolled right past it he brought it
up here's how it works go to quit with
zero calm to start your online doctor
visit after your 5 minute visit of
physician will then determine if you're
eligible to use the quit kit if you're
eligible like they're gonna say no the
doctor will prescribe we don't want
money will prescribe your medication and
the quit kit will be shipped directly to
your door why is that so hard to say
quit kid zero cost less than what the
average smoker spends on cigarettes and
less than other quitting options yeah
how come how expensive our cigarettes
now per pack Nia no I thought you one of
those bad girls smoking in the board
room lies go to quit
with Zen quit with zero dot coms slash
bar and for a limited time my listeners
can get their first month of quit kit to
stop smoking for just thirty seven
dollars that's quit with zero dot com
slash sorry B you are ours all in
capital letters one more time quit with
zero dot com slash / in no Gino talked
to Mia talk about how every man looks
better and feels more confident when he
puts on his suit could you do that for
me every man looks better and it feels
more confident when they put on a suit
what does it do to you when you see me
in a suit when you see my pasty body
launch no you look great in the suit you
know I like the whole habit - yeah I
like that whole look nice bottom I like
a three-piece suit I like a nice tie
good shoes no socks good trousers does
that uh does that increase my chances
later on of getting some sort of
physical contact with you consensual of
course yes
I know in the old days I could just tie
you down with my neckties that was
considered working it out amongst
yourselves all right yeah visit a
stylist what if I wore one of the
bedrooms and I just showed up that's
weird though because that's not I would
like if I just showed up yeah a suit
yeah really yeah and you were like oh
and then it gave you the business yeah
okay all right looks like somebody's
gonna be doing some business with endo
Chino all right
visit a stylist at our showroom and have
them take you measurements personally or
measure at home yourself and shop online
at com choose your fabric inside and out
honey
choose your design customizations submit
your measurements with your choices
relaxed while your suit gets
professionally tailored and mailed to
you in a couple of weeks really fold it
up like a friggin pocket square just
watch as the complements rolled in oh my
November is November is Black Friday see
Nia you guys get more than one month Wow
you get a month in a day you get up even
our kid knows that was messed up hey you
get a month in a day in leap year that's
30 days that's an official month there's
the first you get all 28 days of
February and then that day after
Thanksgiving when my god are you still
on this row people arrest people from
all races trample each other and in a
department store okay that I swear to
god that Black Friday that should be on
the Discovery Channel it's like they
should be doing it you know in the
Serengeti when the water starts drying
up and all of a sudden you know you're a
zebra and you're taking a drink next to
an alligator and there's a lion on the
other side of you it's like those mob
movies when they try to have a truce and
then somebody you know every somebody
screws it up
that was a professional I should have
said all right November is Black Friday
season meaning 2018 s lowest prices up
to 70% off everything the theme is all
about stepping out from backstage making
an entrance takes center stage your big
moment grand finale etc this week my
listeners can can avail can avail of
Black Friday pricing by using code bar
at checkout Cal Capitals that's seventy
percent off the regular price for a made
to suit plus shipping is free
that's Indo Chino calm plus promo code
up to 70% off incredible deal for a
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you don't go back hey Mia can you read
this thing about hair plugs I gotta go
which one hims 66% of men lose their
hair by age 35 or if you are a certain
redheaded comedian before them thing is
when you start to notice thing is when
you start to notice hair loss it's too
late it's easier to keep the hair you
have than a replace the hair you've lost
I ask you why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine and science for hims
calm a one-stop shop a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care sexual wellness for
men thanks to science thanks to science
well I mean don't they kind of go hand
in hand thanks to science baldness can
be optional actually that's the a that's
definitely not sure hims connects you
with real dog Lord that's definitely not
true that's right you came up in the
Michael Jordan era didn't you when
people weren't even bald they just
shaved their head because they wanted to
be like Mike alright where the hell am i
no waiting room no awkward doctor visits
save hours by going to four hens dot-com
for a few quick questions doctors will
review and can prescribe you products
are shipped directly to you dua
my listeners get a free free get a try
now so it get a trial of month of hymns
for just five dollars today it's not
free I was anticipating my listeners get
a trial month of hymns for just five
dollars right now while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to the doctor
or pharmacy go to four hymns calm
football football go you're in national
honey go to four hems calm / / that
that's fo r hims calm / / for hymns calm
/ / alright lastly but not leastly
stamps calm football hockey football if
I stop talking to you ya say go Pat's
[Music]
that's right can you say Tommy that's
right he's the goat he's the best
stamps.com can you say Brad Marshawn
there you go can you say Julian Edelman
can you say Cedeno Chara stop trying to
be all artsy okay can you say Lawrence
Welk
stamps.com stance calm never closes
print postage for letters or packages at
your own convenience 24/7 print posted
you leaving and I thought that was cute
print postage now I got a buzz Nia you
got to plug the Mike Beckett no Jesus
this is what happens when you don't have
a producer can she plug it in yes
stamps Ofcom never closes Nia much like
your legs back in the 90s oh well no yes
and college so ok pre post letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7 print
postage for any mail class right from
your computer the exact amount of
postage every time never under pay or
over pay again stamps.com saves you time
and money which can give you time to
grow your business this
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips
tips buy and print official US postage
for any any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer
stamps.com makes it easy hey take it
easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comb will even help you decide
the best class of mail phone based on
your needs no need to leased an
expensive postage meter and there are no
long term commitments and right now you
too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Barbie you are our
that's stamps comm enter ber all right
and that will be the podcast the
Thursday afternoon football hockey Tom
Brady say bye Dada
okay give me a hug oh that's right oh
wow all right I'll see you buddy
thank you thank you for picking up that
dime very helpful all right that's the
podcast I can't say what I usually say
although I did say a lot of things
didn't I yeah and have a great weekend
you seas enjoy them music and then we'll
have another half-hour bonus what is it
from another half-hour from a Thursday
show earlier this year
oh yeah throwback Thursday though buddy
throwback Thursday there you go all
right
thank you everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
ex-girlfriend sister I hate Billy
Birkenstocks I'm 26 and still in love
with my high school sweetheart we've
been on and off again for 10 years and
have gone through a lot to say the least
Jesus Christ yes I just got back from a
two-week vacation with her where
everything was perfect and we had the
time of our lives this is the woman I
want to start a family with and it
became more and more apparent on this
trip congratulations what could go wrong
here's the thing I slept with her sister
on a drunken blacked-out night three
years ago while me and her were not
together and were on bad terms oh boy my
heart was broken and I had a lot of
resentment I was 23 drunk weak shut the
[ __ ] up dude you had a dick you [ __ ]
jerked off to where while you would date
in her other sit stick get the [ __ ] out
of here
I got a dick too all right don't [ __ ]
and her younger sister came on to me oh
my god you victim things were different
then and I was a mess listen I'm not
saying you weren't [ __ ] heartbroken
you uh you you were [ __ ] psych the
next day there you go you know what you
just got to check off a whole family
well you got left to do is bang them
mother that's got to be called something
like the grand slam you know like when
Tiger Woods won four in a row and they
were saying he won the grand say he won
that you won all four majors would be if
you bang the mother and all the
daughters that would be the Grand Slam
the amount of guys laughter right now
while the women are pissed well a year
or so later me and my high school
sweetheart attacking again it started to
become close leading up to where it is
now I had an unbelievable guilt for what
I did with their sister the the closer
me and this girl got years later it is
the only thing that I haven't been
honest with her about and I had to tell
her you did you should talk to your
sister there's been like look what are
we gonna do here you know
is it how does it make things better
that you told her that's such a and then
like for the rest of their [ __ ] lives
that's gonna be a problem between the
two of them
Jesus you shouldn't have said [ __ ] and
just waited till 20 years later when the
sister you know who never got married
gets [ __ ] hammered and yeah like at
that point you know what are you gonna
do yeah it was dude it was in the
[ __ ] 2000s what do you want from me
anyways he goes well a year or so later
mean and the high-school sweet are
talking again blah blah blah I had an
unbelievable guilt so I had a test so
the last night of our vacation oh my god
we were laying in bed and I told her
everything
I took a slap
she was crying for hours and it was as
ugly as you can imagine well you know
what dude I commend you you got it off
you [ __ ] chest he goes I feel
terrible and I'm torn on if it was the
right decision to tell her my friends
are giving me mixed answers and I would
like an outside perspective from someone
who I respect greatly Jesus quiet he
respect me um I don't know do you if it
was really bugging you and you felt like
you had to tell it good good you told
her you know now you don't have to worry
about that [ __ ] thing coming out of
nowhere he goes it is still fresh and
everything is confusing on what is next
we love each other very much but
obviously I [ __ ] up big time do you
think this relationship stands a chance
I really hope it does but I'm worried I
ruined it she seems to be getting
through it better than I thought after
her first reaction she told me she loves
me but I really hurt her and she needs
some space because when I'm with she
needs some space I hope you don't have a
brother because when I'm with her okay
she told me she loves me but I really
hurt her and she needs some space
because when I'm with her she can't be
mad at me I'm not a scumbag and this is
completely out of character for me to do
I just made a terrible mistake thanks
[ __ ] yourself I will say the fact that
you actually feel this level of guilt
you're a better man than me because I
wouldn't have said [ __ ] I just would
have just been like well I hope this
doesn't [ __ ] come out someday
well we're having pumpkin pie over
Thanksgiving and I bet there's a lot of
people out there that live with that
secret my thing is not only the cowardly
self-preservation that I would try to
have I would also I'm also thinking like
this is I would have handled that
situation I either wouldn't have said
[ __ ] or I would just break up with her
and just walk away from it because I
wouldn't say hey by the way I banged
your sister and then for the rest of
their life they have to [ __ ] deal
with that when I'm the piece of [ __ ]
that did it but I have to commend you
that you actually felt that level of
guilt and said something because I don't
know so it sounds to me that you're
gonna get past it
so the good thing is that now you don't
have to worry about that [ __ ] grand
piano fall crashing down on your [ __ ]
life some day so that's the upside maybe
there's an upside that you told her
where she'll have faith in you that like
wow this guy actually feels guilt about
stuff like that so I can't trust him we
were broken up while it happened you
know let me see if I can get Nia in here
for this one hang on a second all right
the magic of the pause button again the
lovely Nia is here hi hey how you doing
all right
ex-girlfriends sister Oh Gigi yeah all
right really quickly this guy all right
I'll give you a bridge version I've been
on and off Gann for ten years just got
back from a two-week vacation with her
everything was perfect we had the time
of our lives this is the woman I want to
start a family with here's the thing I
slept with his sister and a drunken
blacked out night three years ago while
we met well while we me and her were not
together and we're on bad turns my heart
was broken I had a
resentment I was 23 drunk week and her
younger sister came on to me I don't
know I'd say that's the rough one you
like how he makes himself to victim yeah
she came on to me okay I said early said
dude I have a dick too don't [ __ ] lie
to me exactly I said I said you rubbed
one out to her before you [ __ ] for a
while that you've been wanting to [ __ ]
the sister don't try to act like oh I
was so heartbroken you and the sister
are both dirty okay so here's a deal he
goes he felt terrible the last night of
the vacation he couldn't deal with the
guilt so he told her he goes I tell he
goes I took a slap
she was crying for hours and it was as
ugly as you can imagine yeah all right
she told me she loves me but I really
hurt her and she needs some space
because when I'm with with her she can't
be mad at me I'm not a scumbag and this
is completely out of character for me to
do I just made a terrible mistake so
he's basically saying do you think the
relationship stands a chance I really
hope it does but I'm worried I ruined it
she seems to be getting through it
better than I thought after our first
reaction what do you think yeah no it's
it's not gonna happen you [ __ ] her
sister it's over that's it I think so
yeah because I mean maybe maybe there
are some people who are more emotionally
evolved than I am but I couldn't get
that like that's her sister like her
sister's not going anywhere and like how
is it gonna be at like Thanksgiving and
Christmas and like all that kind of
stuff like you're just gonna avoid each
other or just kind of like it's weird I
mean maybe the three of them can have a
threesome what I was thinking you can't
you can't have a threesome with your
sister that's disgusting
that's gross I would never want to be
just caesarian Annie no looking to each
other in these Bocking to each other
Hey hello we went to the water park Oh
oh stop unless the three of them sit
down and both this guy and the sister
are so repentant and so whatever but
like you you'd never be able to trust
them you never know like oh yeah can you
guys run out and like you know get some
extra sugar and our groceries exactly so
and that's the thing she might be okay
with him now but in the end she's gonna
choose her sister like that no matter
how her sister betrayed her that's the
sister so you are disposable you're just
like the dude that's her family so if
you think that you really I feel like
hands on to the her and the sister yes
her and the sister will probably get
past it is she what long a long long
ways from now and it will probably
always still be there but because
they're family family betrays each other
all the time you know no it's a thing I
think what she did was worse than what
he did
the sister yeah oh definitely if we're
gonna like put them on who was the worst
person the situation the sister 100% so
here's what I learned you never do that
if you're with the woman okay okay you
guys break up and blah blah blah if her
sister comes on to you like you are
effectively ending that relationship
forever yeah yeah you can solder her and
the relationship you think he should
have told her the thing about it is is
that he told her because he felt guilty
so it was to unburden his own conscience
because it wasn't real because there's
nothing in telling her that would make
her feel better and oh my God thank you
so much for being honest with me that's
the sister so I don't know I I don't
really say it's nothing commendable that
he had such guilt that he had to tell
her not really because people are made
with shielding all the time and they
like oh I just had to get it off my
chest and it's like great
congratulations it's off your chest now
I feel shitty so was that really for me
or was that for you do you Renee Hill
coming here bringing the love
yeah I I I don't I don't I'm not with
that whole like well at least he was
honest with you it's like for what for
me no that was all for him too I never
looked at it that way Wow
yeah not that I don't think apologies
are worthwhile or I don't it's not like
I don't think that you should apologize
for something you did wrong but I just
feel like you really need to probably
hoping that's what you were saying yeah
you really questioning your motivations
for confessing something of this level
you know what I mean it's like what are
you really trying to do a lot of times
people are just trying to unburden
themselves well that's what I was saying
that the best thing now is he got it out
there so he doesn't have to worry about
that grand piano coming crashing down
into his life someday like a family they
haven't like [ __ ] Thanksgiving dinner
what I want to know is what is going on
between the girl and the sister cuz
obviously that's no sister that's no
real I don't know that's what I'm with
something else why that's [ __ ] up is
because now you know that the parents
know you know you think she would have
told the parents like but if they no way
Brad yeah and then they gotta be like oh
my god we raised a [ __ ] eggs but that's
really that's that's issues no no that's
that's beyond that's a power thing yet
it is a hold of power it is I wonder if
this was a younger sister and I wonder
like who knows but that's what I'm more
intrigued about now it's like what's
gonna happen with these sisters you know
that's like that's some deep [ __ ] right
there so no no that's like a power thing
on her thing saying like you know as
much as you're into her you still can't
[ __ ] resist me what is it yeah maybe
so because who does that who goes after
the ìletís into the female mind I can't
let you on that that's not a female
thing that's like a dirty ass ho [ __ ]
nasty person I don't know what that's
like I would never go after a relatives
like significant other so where do you
draw the line
what do you mean coworker so you're not
just so the people know because you
really have strong opinions on this so I
want to know so family obviously yeah
Neffe yeah is clearly in a relationship
with somebody else and you know got all
that together I want to know I want to
know where you draw the line coworker
you okay you guys occasionally have
lunch together with the sisters coworker
yeah and there's something the guys got
like he does like the the paisley tie
with the suspenders you know that yeah
yeah you guys always go nuts about no
belt
yeah well if you have suspenders you
don't need about some but anyway um what
if he has both suspenders and a belt and
then you think like what it is that
you're trying to do well maybe how would
you have both when that wouldn't like
get that thing that female thing were
like you'd feel safe like this guy's
really gonna have like he's gonna have
an alarm system and a gun yeah I'm gonna
sword and then wear two condoms yeah no
I mean if they're not involved if
they're not like in a real relationship
neighbors yeah behavor don't you would
you bang a neighbor what I bang like my
sister would neighbor no not your
sisters no but taking family out of it
I'm saying where where is the line where
it's just like well whatever [ __ ] you
know isn't that you guys say you put the
hand up whatever [ __ ] but what are you
talking about I'm saying cuz you saying
like that's family you can't [ __ ] do
that I'm just trying to find a comedic
angle here no I see what you mean I mean
neighbor two streets over your neighbor
knew them invited you over and you went
over there you know what I have a
real-life example of this guy what guy
was an architect okay all right I got it
example of this durka during my prom I
went my senior prom I love your dirty
yeah wait a minute I went with somebody
who's just a friend okay but there's
work a friend is Biz Markie
[Laughter]
um but my friend went to the prom with
this guy that she had just met and they
were set up by another friend different
school so they didn't really like know
each other justification they was set up
my friends so I'm totally innocent so we
really connected during prom and like as
you know that was not what happened as
you know my prom did not end that great
my parents like came and like took me
from this house that I was in because I
was dumb enough wait to tell them the
truth I called my parents because I was
supposed to spend the night at a
girlfriend's house but instead we're
gonna be hanging out at this boy's house
his older sister was there there was a
whole bunch of us we were hanging out I
was having such a great time that I
called my parents and I said hey just so
you know I'm staying here my mom
completely flipped out and she and my
stepfather came and like extracted me
from the home so prom ended exactly so
it didn't end on any it was a very
traumatic but rape parents ultimately
they did the right thing um but anyway
he me and this guy ended up connecting
and we ended up like dating afterward so
you know um oh that's different I
thought you seemed like you know like I
we went in the bathroom went to the
front part of the limo and put the
window up no no no but it wasn't her
boyfriend they had just met I think she
definitely felt some type of way about
it you know only because he chose you
over her exactly you guys didn't have
any sort of like friendship friendship
no she and I were really good friends
yeah that you know no that's not good
that's a rough one but it wasn't Oh
brand a lot of rough one thing little
rough ones and we dated for a while we
dated up until you know like I went to
college basically and that was that was
the end of that so it wasn't like this
long term you know torrid affair it
wasn't like he was my first love or
anything he was just really cute and a
football player and lights Bob Marley
you know hey what can I say
I'm sort of sorted sort of details here
all right well that's the podcast for
this week
cheesy he came hard this week he came
hard you really [ __ ] just put that
guy he just said you know what then
that's it it's a [ __ ] wrapping you
know what I think you're right I think
you're right
I can say that yeah as I sit here in my
paint yes yeah
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 15th 2010 and I'm doing
this one really really really [ __ ]
late I had to fly back from Columbus
this weekend Columbus Ohio and before I
start the podcast I want to thank
everyone who came out to my shows I had
six phenomenal shows out there every
damn one of them sold out people smiling
and waving I was shaking hands and
kissing babies after shows everything
was great so I want to thank everyone
who came out
seriously man that was amazing the Sun
even the sunday show sold out so
definitely definitely gonna be back you
know cuz that's how I do it if you show
up to my shows then I come back to your
town you know the [ __ ] you think I'm
doing this [ __ ] for free people only the
podcast is free um but even that it's
anything free there's a price to pay for
everything my girl is [ __ ] pissed at
me right now because my apartment was so
goddamn quiet until I came home and she
was praying to God that I had already
done the podcast and she was asking me
did you read did you already do it did
you do it and I said no I have to do the
podcast and she was just like just so
nice and quiet so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna do a more subdued podcast this
week I'm just [ __ ] with you
I live to irritate people alright so I'm
gonna be doing it alright what the [ __ ]
am I talking about I just got off the
plane
alright back from Columbus what the [ __ ]
do I want to talk about I don't [ __ ]
know I'm starting to take pictures of
people sleeping in airports just some
other [ __ ] faces you know especially
on the planes when people don't bring
those neck braces
you know those people like they're
[ __ ] sooo happy people during the day
and at night they fly in planes and they
have those little neck braces one when
people don't have those just watching
people's heads bobbing all around you
know that's a good time to be obese
because you got like that built-in neck
brace big neck brace of fat you know you
want a pillow all you do is just lean
your head 45 degrees to the right of the
left you're all good I bet they never
have any neck pain you know but what do
they do every [ __ ] week on The
Biggest Loser sitting that [ __ ] moaning
and complaining it would so [ __ ] hard
really you have a body temperature
pillow on all four sides of your neck
I know it's round but my world you still
have sides so there you go fatties fat
people I know and I know I tease you a
lot because you know what I'm sick of
you I'm citizen you know there's enough
[ __ ] groups out there that I gotta
watch what I say
that I got a tippy-toe around okay I'm
not ticking I'm not [ __ ] adding
another one all right
I've added up to here with the [ __ ]
tippy-toeing goddamn bastards lay off
the fudge I first realized I was out of
control when I went to fall asleep on
the plane and I felt like I was laying
on a cloud and I realized it was part of
my neck Jesus how [ __ ] cranky am i
when I get off a goddamn plane
anyways I was a good boy out in Columbus
as far as boozing goes I did not booze
as far as eating goes I did all right
you know you know so [ __ ] funny is
when you go to the goddamn Midwest and
you try to ask people where can I get
something healthy to eat like
that I think there's no such thing as
healthy food in the Midwest they don't
even [ __ ] understand it you know all
they know how to do is to have some big
blockheaded [ __ ] blonde haired kid
come out of their goddamn wife's [ __ ]
[ __ ] right
they don't even raise him they just send
him out in the [ __ ] cornfields and
just just have the kid the kid grazes
until he's [ __ ] 16 all right then
they sign him up for Pop Warner [ __ ]
football they can't even find a helmet
to fit his big [ __ ] big ten goddamn
butcher block of a [ __ ] head right
and then what happens some piece of [ __ ]
can't beat him so what do they do they
[ __ ] crack one of the crack back
block whatever the [ __ ] they take his
[ __ ] knees out all right his dreams
over
he's not gonna block for jim plunkett
it's [ __ ] over so that what he gets a
job at a [ __ ] hotel desk and there I
come walking in you know the [ __ ]
[ __ ] California boy now go know it
excuse me is there place to get
something healthy and these [ __ ]
people they're their eyes crossed I said
this all I said you know I'm really
craving a steak Dez is there a place to
get a steak and I don't mean like an
apple beef steak you know what I mean
I'm talking cloth napkins I'm talking
you know somebody related to a
Rockefeller sitting at the bar sipping
on some goddamn old booze talking to a
broad seventy years younger than him
that's that's the kind of [ __ ] place
I want to go to all right that's what I
want to go to you know what this [ __ ]
goddamn idiot said he sends me to some
[ __ ] barbecue shack I'm walking
towards it like you know I don't have a
car so I'm walking around the hotel and
as I'm walking towards the complex he
told me to go to one of the first red
flags I saw was a neon sign all right we
got any steak eaters out there who
listen to this [ __ ] podcast yeah do
you like a quality steak do you like
going to a quality place exactly now
have you ever seen a [ __ ] neon sign
neon signage
does Peter Lugar's have neon signage I
don't think so
huh Smith of Wollensky now it's always
supposed to look stuffy it's supposed to
look like there's politicians in there
doing [ __ ] dirty backdoor deals for
[ __ ] defense contracts that's what
it's supposed to look like all right
[ __ ] guys in suits that's what it's
supposed to look like and I come walking
in and you know I don't have enough time
before the show so I just say [ __ ] it
and I go over there right and I walk
into this barbecue joint and if you guys
have listened to this podcast before you
realize I [ __ ] hate barbecue I don't
like it it doesn't taste good I think
the sauce is just their way of covering
up the fact that you're eating a very
poor cut of meat you know eating the
[ __ ] cartilage out of a goddamn oxen
or whatever the hell they do the pig ear
sandwich is it really did you get all
the cartilage in there you [ __ ] [ __ ]
no wonder you got to slather it with all
that smoked Hickory whatever the fire
snack seasoned know what you cook it
with whatever with all the barbecue
sauce so I go in there you know and I'm
[ __ ] grumbling like the goddamn
[ __ ] old man I am so I open up the
menu and I just you know something just
pops out at me it's just pulled pork
they got some some broccoli and some
beans and I say [ __ ] it you know his
cute girl comes over right like the
roundest tits I've seen in a long time
was [ __ ] that perfectly [ __ ] round
and they weren't fake and I was just
kept looking at him going how are they
so [ __ ] round and I was like you know
what she probably has on one of those
[ __ ] hocus-pocus bras that's what it
is she's probably got an A cup possibly
a B Cup and I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing that padded but you know
still it was fun to look at she had one
of those bras that I think Doug Henning
made and master of illusion Doug Henning
um he's a magician everybody the big
space in between his teeth like that
[ __ ] guy used to play for the Giants
who's now on television who had a failed
sitcom and I could
never remember his [ __ ] name
yeah you ever have something like that
you just can't remember the [ __ ] name
and the same facial hair as rosey Grier
the [ __ ] is his name
one of the great defensive ends of all
time broke the sack record remember that
when [ __ ] Brett Favre curled up into
the fetal position because they were
friends the [ __ ] is his name he plays
for the goddamn Giants ah [ __ ] the [ __ ]
he thinking Richard Seymour I know
that's the guy the Patriots shouldn't
have traded the [ __ ] is his name begins
with an S there's an S in there
somewhere that guy could [ __ ] he
could spit a walnut at you between his
two front teeth not even opening his
goddamn mouth um anyway so I go in there
and I [ __ ] order that [ __ ] and I'm
just looking at this girl with their
round tits right and she brings the
stuff over and they got this little you
know they got the Kansas City which is a
sweet that's a sweet sweeter one and
then you got Carolina's more vinegar
base and then we got we got the [ __ ]
Mexican one that's gonna make your eyes
water and your nose run and then they
had one other one the the [ __ ] one
right so I go with the Kansas City one
and I got to tell you it was one of the
best [ __ ] meals I've had in a long
time it was absolute the pork was
absolutely delicious
I loved it the beans were phenomenal the
broccoli of course had been steaming
since they opened the place because
nobody in the Midwest eats vegetables
they're horrible people man they all got
big heads and blocked colons you know
that's why they play that Smash Mouth
football they're not gonna use a spread
offense they're all [ __ ] clogged up uh
just [ __ ] around people I'm just
[ __ ] around I'm going on adrenaline
here all right I'm going on adrenaline
that's all I got it's all I got this
week so actually I that's the one time
when I didn't eat well and I'm gonna
talk about food this week I went to
[ __ ] pen Aunt Panama anima Panorama
[ __ ] Panera Bread whatever the [ __ ]
you call it went in there and I got a
breakfast sandwich hi sir I can help you
down here sir yes thank you sir come
down to this register sir thank you sir
hi there can I help you sir one of those
places where it's like did somebody
drugged you you know did Alec Baldwin of
Panera Bread come in and scream [ __ ] you
with you
you know the whole Glengarry Glen Ross
and now you're out here what with you
know just trying to be all [ __ ] happy
stop beating not that happy
so anyways sir can I help you sorry sir
I can help you down here I get up the
next person down here sir can you down
come down here sir so I go down there I
go let me get a make it a breakfast
sandwich okay we have our choice between
egg and cheese egg cheese and sausage or
egg cheese and bacon I go let me get the
egg and cheese what kind of bread kind
of bread you got what do you got the
hickory-smoked we got the salmon flat
[ __ ] it just give me wheat okay sir
there's no reason to curse right so I
get the wheat and they just microwave
this [ __ ] I don't know it was one of the
most it was almost like a joke sandwich
like a prop sandwich like the kind of
thing that would be sitting on a plate
in the background and that old show was
at pee-wee's Playhouse pee-wee's
funhouse pee-wee's let's give some kids
some acid and invite a pedophile over
whatever the [ __ ] his show was called I
don't know see adrenaline doesn't always
work that was a that was a [ __ ] sandwich
and this story was even shittier but
anyway so this is the [ __ ] podcast
for this week I need help from you guys
all right I went out and I bought some
RAM for my computer my whole
do-it-yourself kick
all right I know I could have gone down
to the Apple store and had one of those
[ __ ] nerds their goddamn body odor
walking around with the nerve they have
you know genius written on their shirt
all right with their Buddy Holly glasses
and that type of [ __ ] and I'm like how
[ __ ] hard can it be to put RAM in a
computer that sounds pretty intimidating
doesn't it well you know what I went on
YouTube and evidently it's pretty
[ __ ] easy take a goddamn nickel out
of your pocket right
you unscrew the [ __ ] battery for some
reason you you you turn right to loosen
it you know lefty-loosey righty-tighty
you have to go right pop out the [ __ ]
battery and there's like two screws you
remove a band and then there's two
switches and the things pop out like
toast you take out the old one you put
in the higher one you slam that [ __ ]
back in you just do the reverse process
and you're done
but this is the problem you need special
screwdrivers all right you need
precision screwdrivers and I went down
to [ __ ] Home Depot and they don't
have any small enough so now that I have
insulted all the tech nerds out there
where the [ __ ] can I get these
screwdrivers I have a Mac OS X or is
that ten I have no idea
version ten point five point eight I
need some precision screwdrivers to
unscrew [ __ ] three four bolts you
know I feel like I'm gonna I'm gonna put
a [ __ ] Hemi in my laptop it's a joke
you guys should go on YouTube go on
YouTube and check her going the mmm
podcasts cuz we'll have this video calm
mmm podcast calm we'll have that video
up there just look up YouTube videos how
to add RAM to your Mac and this guy will
show you how to do the whole [ __ ]
thing it's a joke alright this is my new
kick I'm sick of these [ __ ] guys with
their Dickies come walking into my
apartment charging me all this goddamn
money and not one of them
seems like they're any smarter than I am
so basically they just have information
information who are the new number two
who is number one you are number six I
am NOT a number I am a free man sorry
Iron Maiden flashback yeah I'm sick of
these guys coming in here charging me
all this [ __ ] money I want to know
how to do [ __ ] myself I'm still trying
to get the balls up to replace the trim
on my doors I've gotten to the point
where I've watched enough YouTube videos
where I definitely know how to get the
[ __ ] off lace most weekend warriors oh I
can start the [ __ ] job but bringing
it on home you know it's gonna be
hilarious and/or great for my act is
when I actually try to do this [ __ ] and
fail and then I have to call another guy
over to finish it because I wasn't man
enough to figure it out myself
and it'll be emasculating but you know
what I'll learn I'll stay I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't have any goddamn pride at
this point I'll stand right there and
figure out look over his shoulder I'll
be that annoying guy huh
oh you blue-collar guys out there who
fix [ __ ] I did that for a minute I used
to finish basements you know and the
[ __ ] worst job you could ever do is
you go into somebody's [ __ ] house did
go into finish their basement and the
[ __ ] [ __ ] would be sitting down there
in the basement watching you do the
entire project so anytime you made a bad
cut anytime you know oh you know all the
[ __ ] that's behind the walls there's
a lot of knee and elbow work and they're
sitting there freaking out what is that
is that is that gonna be a problem
like when you go to put the [ __ ]
insulation in you know
I can't remember the [ __ ]
measurements I was I was a grunt I just
handed the dude the [ __ ] and I remember
that like the [ __ ] insulation would
go like 80% up the wall and then you
just reach over and break off some more
insulation and stuff it in there and the
[ __ ] goddamn broads would get so
pissed what what about that little space
in between it's not gonna matter why are
you here do you think we're gonna steal
your [ __ ] laundry get out of here the
[ __ ] out of here that was a big night
then you know what's funny is you just
sit there and and the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
would go on between me and the other
person I was finished in the basement
with you know when we realized the
person wasn't leaving do they do would
just be like yeah hand me the nail gun
and you know you do that [ __ ] where
we're like the douche is behind you
right
it's basically he's talking to me I can
see his face and over his shoulder I see
the person who owns the [ __ ] house
and he turned to me like hand me that
nail gun and you know his eyes would be
wide and his eyebrows would be down you
know that look like [ __ ] [ __ ] so anyways
that's probably what's gonna end up
happening me so this is the Monday
morning podcast overtly subdued version
of the Monday morning podcast for
November 15th and guess what's it guess
what everybody cuz I stutter through
this [ __ ] thing it is November 15th
an old billy boy here has got 30 days
and no boozing
no booze not a drop of [ __ ] booze how
do you like that for [ __ ] willpower
it's not that impressive is it well
[ __ ] means a lot to me I was actually
on the plain reading Rolling Stone
Eminem is on the cover and he was
talking about two and a half years of
being sober and I was thinking I was
pretty [ __ ] amazing considering the
most I've been able to go 75 days you
know
I granted I don't feel like I have an
addictive personality I just don't want
to have a huge fat head although I could
use the side of my neck for a pillow
when I get on the goddamn plane so
anyways this is the podcast for this
week last week I actually began a new
segment here on the podcast
inadvertently when I when I brought up
that movie over the edge and when those
kids riot in the school and they locked
the police and the parents and the
teachers because they were having that
meeting in the cafeteria they lock him
in the [ __ ] cafeteria and then they
started vandalizing the school and the
cop runs up and he's tugging on the
[ __ ] chain-link fence or whatever the
[ __ ] they put up and he can't get out
and this chick big chick like six foot
two comes running by with this giant
globe she runs by the camera and then
comes running back looks at the cop and
goes eat it you stinking Pig what about
one of the most [ __ ] horrific lines
I've ever seen in a [ __ ] movie and
that ended up inadvertently creating a
new segment best lines in awful movies
and I got one for you
it is called shark attack I can't tell
you what the line is you have to watch
somebody sent this in I should say it's
a shark attack three
just just search we're gonna have all of
these all of this ship ship sorry up on
I'm actually apologizing because I
didn't curse sorry I said ship and set a
[ __ ] world could have all these videos
up on the mmm podcast calm alright but
for some reason if you want to look it
up yourself if you're control freak I
understand that go ahead make your life
harder I don't give a [ __ ] go on youtube
and look up shark attack three famous
line and I challenge you to be silence
after you [ __ ] hear what this guy
says I think I just said what
it just it's the most
one of the most [ __ ] up lines I've
ever heard in a movie and you know what
that that's the challenge give me a line
worse than this [ __ ] line in shark
attack three famous line and also I was
kind of surfing I started surfing bad
movies because I got into that part on
YouTube and I definitely must rent a
definite rental for me I'm taking a
month off here coming up around
Christmas is Silent Night deadly night
part 5 I have to watch that [ __ ]
movie there's another great one just
just go on YouTube and [ __ ] just look
at the movie just look at the trailer
for that [ __ ] movie
you know somebody asked me the other
days like you know as an actor when
you're in a bad movie do you think you
realize it you know
I think on a movie like that you do but
the scary thing is is I think on
anything else you don't because you so
it the [ __ ] mercy of the music of the
edits and all that type of [ __ ] you just
pray to God you got somebody good that's
what I learned in date night when I
delivered eight [ __ ] lines listen to
me talking like I'm in and inside the
Actor's [ __ ] studio I had eight lines
more than a goddamn extra and Here I am
talking like I'm a [ __ ] professional
why do I have the hiccups
so anyways there you go people there's
21 minutes where I didn't talk about
sports alright so be prepared to roll
your [ __ ] eyes all right let's talk
NFL football real quick here I went one
in three this week betting against the
spread I got my [ __ ] ass handed a
[ __ ] ass handed to me I knew the
second yeah you know gamblers out there
you know like those certain weeks where
you just you just can't see a winner
some weeks you get excited you like I'll
[ __ ] this is easy man like that they'll
definitely cover they're definitely
cover course half of them don't but I'm
not even talking about whether you're
winning you lose but you have that
excitement like yeah I can [ __ ] see
it right you know you're like that the
black dude who's who's constantly
shaving his head and predator I see you
over there in them trees right you're
looking at it like that this week I was
more like Tom Cruise and Top Gun you
know when he loses his edge he's going
yet good you know turn the [ __ ] plane
around you [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you
doing
right knee just ass no good I can't see
anything that that's how I was this week
I just you know I
look at the bills and liens and I just
didn't like it hated that [ __ ] game
you know those two goddamn
jekyll-and-hyde teams who the [ __ ]
gonna show up you know so I stayed away
from that one I looked at [ __ ] Miami
and the Ravens and something was telling
me Chad Pennington Chad Pennington but I
was like against Ray Lewis and [ __ ]
Ralph Nader whatever the [ __ ] the name
of this quarterback is it for some
reason I can't remember Eddie Falco Edie
Falco what the [ __ ] is his name Flacco
Joe Flacco so I said my gut told me
Miami but I didn't have the balls I
didn't have the balls to pull the
trigger so I said [ __ ] that one all
right so I bet Tampa Bay cuz they've
been working for me and they covered and
then I just picked two games why just
couldn't I couldn't see a [ __ ] winner
I bet that uh the Houston Texans against
Jacksonville I was getting a point to
half I said goddamn jekyll-and-hyde
Jacksonville who's gonna show up Texans
have been consistent [ __ ] they beat
the Colts I'm going with the Texas all
right lose that goddamn [ __ ] bet on
that Hail Mary pass all right but that
happens and then I looked at the Arizona
Seattle game and I picked Arizona and I
said no wait Seattle Seattle let's say
happy Carol's not a [ __ ] NFL coach
and I picked Arizona as I was saying not
at Seattle so I [ __ ] lose that one
and this was the worst one Pittsburgh
plays my [ __ ] New England Patriots
and I was so goddamn [ __ ] depressed
after that Browns loss the Steelers are
at home and they're only given [ __ ]
four and a half they got that great
defense they got Ben Roethlisberger Joe
[ __ ] cool won two Super Bowls
they held a lot
water with me so I said [ __ ] it I'm
taking the goddamn steel is I bet
against my own [ __ ] team and I lost
that one
I was doing my Sunday night show at the
funny bone in Columbus and I get
offstage and I'm going it's gonna be
like 17 3 or 17 to 9 or something
Pittsburgh and I get offstage and it's
[ __ ] 10 to nothing Patriots and I was
like you gotta be [ __ ] me
right you know that's sinking feeling
you're like you gotta be kidding me
really really I lost faith in my own
[ __ ] team I'm not gonna be able to
enjoy this actually I still did enjoy it
it's kind of a win-win for me either the
Patriots get their [ __ ] asses kicked
right but it helps my gambling record or
they go out and win but the thing is is
I didn't bet on the Patriots so I can't
brag this week I can't even bring up the
fact that we [ __ ] own the Pittsburgh
Steelers we are seven and two against
those [ __ ] the last nine games
the six-time world champion that the
[ __ ] Yankees of the NFL the Boston
Celtics of the NFL the Montreal
Canadiens the ones with the most [ __ ]
titles we have seven and two and I for
the life of me I can't figure out why
remember a few like a month ago when all
the jet fans had their stupid green
chest hairs standing at attention and I
was saying that Roethlisberger hadn't
come back yet and that's the team that's
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you or until
you beat that [ __ ] team that that's
the team that I believed it I know what
the [ __ ] happened
I don't know so anyways and being in
Columbus I actually got to watch the
Browns and the Jets game and uh you know
what I don't [ __ ] what the Browns
like Cleveland fans I don't know what
the [ __ ] you guys did to the sports gods
that's another one of those [ __ ]
towns it's just like they just can't
lose a game they have to [ __ ] it up you
know by the way can I
any credit on this podcast for that stat
that I created remember I told you I
said mark [ __ ] Sanchez leads the
league and drop in her dropped
interceptions
any fantasy football nerds want to start
keeping track of that I've never seen
anything like it
it's like he's got a little remote
control in the football that when
defenders catch it with both hands it's
I don't know what he does like he's he's
got like he turns it into a knuckleball
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
I'm joking he's actually a good
quarterback that [ __ ] guy
he threw a pick he throws a pick I could
have caught the ball it hit this dude in
both [ __ ] hands
but because Sanchez throws it the dude
just goes wall a he took it like your
leg it was a hot potato just sort of
threw it past himself and then he's like
whoa no wait I think I want to catch it
now and at that point the jet 2 wide
receiver wisely slapped it to the
[ __ ] ground you know I don't in
defense of the Jets I mean they did miss
three [ __ ] field goals so they should
have won at regulation but Jesus Christ
they opened the [ __ ] door that's what
scaring me about the Jets is they
[ __ ] lose games and they still win
they got luck be a lady tonight they got
that on their side and you know what jet
fans cuz I know you have no idea what
it's like to win a championship alright
that's what you need when you start
seeing [ __ ] like that that's the kind of
[ __ ] that should get you excited and
scares the [ __ ] out of me because if you
[ __ ] are actually going to be a
halfway decent team and the people are
gonna drop interceptions I mean how do
you stop that even when they're trying
to lose a [ __ ] game they're still
winning games but jet fans you got to
admit how [ __ ] insane is that running
back I told you that guy who's I keep
forgetting his name the guy with the
Dodge Ram grille on the front of his
[ __ ] helmet who the [ __ ] was talking
about his arms was saying that's why he
fumbled the ball
oh that [ __ ] they were right in
field goal just step out of bounds
protect the [ __ ] ball whatever here's
my prediction I think Cleveland very
quickly is gonna get over LeBron leaving
and they're gonna become a football town
once again and I am off
or because I [ __ ] loved the Cleveland
Browns in the 80s I love those teams
Brian Sipe Bernie Kosar that [ __ ]
orange helmet used to play in Municipal
Stadium and it was always like [ __ ]
minus 60 degrees ah those games with a
[ __ ] those games with a [ __ ] [ __ ]
cardiac kids right I don't know you know
what I actually get excited when a team
that that's been bad for a long time but
actually used to have a winning
tradition like the Browns were the [ __ ]
in the 50s right through the 60s you
know that's something I should have
looked up I should have looked up how
many NFL titles that they that they want
isn't that [ __ ] up that they they
don't count those you know what I mean
how the Pittsburgh Steelers era topped
the league with a measly six
championships it's not a measly because
they've won it in the last 40-something
years but like six championships is all
it takes for you to get to the top of
the league
you know it's [ __ ] 27 in baseball 17
in basketball I always figure out what
the Canadians got the Canadians got like
[ __ ] they got at least 22
something like that Jesus Christ some
[ __ ] French douche is gonna correct
me on that one
all in capital letters squiggly lines
over different vowels yeah I don't why I
don't think anybody know why why don't
they count those titles you know why
don't they they count like me would it
be nice if Eagle fans could actually
have like 1960 or whatever the [ __ ] they
had at least some sort of championship
banner hanging on top of the [ __ ]
blimpy Subway sandwich com stadium
whatever that whatever the [ __ ] they
play I don't think why don't they count
those does anybody know is this even
[ __ ] remotely interesting let's get
to do the obscure sports stat of the
week somebody sent this [ __ ] in you know
last week I started this topic by saying
how the last time sports teams in st.
Louis lost a World Series lost a Stanley
Cup final lost a Super Bowl and an NBA
title way back when they had the st.
Louis Hawks before they moved to Atlanta
the last four times they've lost in the
finals last times they've lost in the
finals in all four sports is what I'm
trying to say we're all from teams all
at the hands of teams from Boston
there's your obscure stat from last week
and this is the one from this week all
right this is the most fucked-up thing
I've seen in a while evidently back in
all right the glam-rock was going on all
right let's give you a little historical
perspective I think this is right during
Watergate when did Nixon get bounced out
like 74 that's right cuz he won in 72
and then the fallout was in 73 and then
he was gone
what else happened we got out of Vietnam
as a year before we got out of Vietnam
and I know chicks are pretty hot back
then you know that whole Mary Tyler
Moore look and I was never into Mary
Tyler Moore she looked better on that
show with that skinny drunk he used to
fall over the Ottoman but Dick Van Dyke
was the other ones the ones that did the
guest stars and they had they had the
[ __ ] miniskirts no miniskirts you
know barely hanging over those [ __ ]
hairy muffs anyways there's your
historical perspective to Yankee
pitchers in 1973 I never heard of this
traded their wives and kids
switched off families and this is the
story according to the Daily News 1973
Fort Lauderdale Florida March March
March 5th Yankee pitcher they'd gone by
their last names here because I guess
you know people know who the [ __ ] they
were kekaa CH kek i CH and maryland
disclosed today that they had exchanged
families several months ago
Peterson moving in with Susan Keck rich
and her two daughters and Keck rich
moving in with Maryland Peterson and our
two sons
the pitchers in separate talks said they
decided to reveal the arrangement
because too many people knew about it
evidently everybody in baseball I mean
you can't really keep a story like that
quiet
I guess all around the [ __ ] spring
training everybody was talking about
this [ __ ] so they finally just went
public with it so they thought it was
time to clear the air and the 31 year
old Peterson confided that they hope
that you won't make anything sorted out
of this according to kekaa ch I'm sure
I'm saying that wrong unless people know
the full details it could turn out to be
a nasty type thing don't say this was
wipe swathing his wife swapping because
it wasn't we didn't swap wives we
swapped lives ah Jesus Christ look at
this guy [ __ ] sprinkling a bunch of
sugar over it I guess technically he is
right dude how [ __ ] up with their
children
check it your dad just taps out yeah I'm
out of here I don't want to be with your
mom anymore and you know you know my
best buddy he was always over here
drinking beers yeah he's gonna be your
dad now he's gonna be banging your mom
when you hear that moaning just know
that's not me doing that work all right
kids and I'm out of here
and I'm gonna go [ __ ] his wife and go
raise his children okay how does that
sit with you
Jesus Christ you want to talk up if they
had daughters you want to talk about the
easiest chicks to lose your [ __ ]
virginity to then there you go right
there
there they are line em up fellas all
right New Jersey where the four have
resided for four years requires simply
that the parties prove separation for a
year in order to file for divorce
it's a no-fault rule meaning no grounds
are required you know what's amazing
about this [ __ ] story is how like
that you could actually keep something
like this quiet for for a couple of
months because if you ever try to do any
[ __ ] like this today I mean Jesus
Christ three different 24 hours sports
networks in ESPN alone the vs Network I
mean then you got TMZ would jump well
that was just TMZ
late-night talk shows they got like 58
of them now
oh my god be over manager Ralph Houk
said it was a situation that he could
live with that it would not rip apart
his team and that it still had its best
chance of winning a pennant since 1964
I always liked Ralph Houk [ __ ] kept
it positive and just for the record they
went 80 and 82 two games of under 500
jesus [ __ ] christ
Jesus Christ how the [ __ ] do you top
that obscure stat has anybody noticed
that I've been stuttering more and more
as his [ __ ] podcast goes along the
Sun is gradually going down I got 36
stutter in [ __ ] minutes in here hang
on a second I got to turn the light on
so I can read here hold on across the
street how the [ __ ] do I mean talk to me
that was like the fallout of the the the
free love man society's rules man what
does it mean you know it's funny is they
they really I saw a great documentary on
on hippies is literally called hippies
and it was awesome because one of the
former hippie dudes was really honest
where he just said he didn't like what
was going on and he rebelled against it
which I totally [ __ ] related to but he
talked about living in those communes
you know where they were gonna start
their own [ __ ] churches and their own
education and everything and everybody
shared everything and he came to the
same conclusion that we all come to is
that basically other people are [ __ ]
irritating and you want to get away from
him and that's basically what happened
at the communal East for this guy like
he was hanging out and have free love
and all this type of [ __ ] and after a
while you just like oh my god I got I
gotta get I gotta get the [ __ ] away from
these people you know so you really got
to hand it to the Native Americans how
they were able to live like that and
somehow
you know why that is of course is
because they didn't realize they didn't
understand the concept of having an
apartment much less a [ __ ] door all
right that was pretty ignorant let's
plow ahead oh by the way I've really
pissed off a lot of potheads evidently
on my podcast they think that I am
against smoking weed and then I'm
trashing that whole [ __ ] lifestyle
why don't you guys go take another hit
off you [ __ ] blunt and [ __ ] relax
alright just because I trashed that guy
who was a pot smoker I wasn't saying
that weed was a bad thing all right at
this point with those vaporizers that
they have it's probably [ __ ] ten
times healthier than sitting around
drinking a six-pack I don't have a
[ __ ] problem I wasn't talking about
smoking weed I was I wasn't I was making
fun of a loser I was telling that woman
that she was dating a [ __ ] loser all
right as a man your job is to go out and
[ __ ] provide you know and when
somebody breaks into your house not to
[ __ ] yourself and to grab the nearest
blunt object and [ __ ] go Braveheart
on them that's what you're supposed to
do you know me I would [ __ ] myself lock
myself in the bathroom and call 9-1-1 of
course but I can provide goddammit
that's when I got a fifth [ __ ] pit
bull for speaking of that I watched No
Country for Old Men again man what a
[ __ ] awesome movie that is that's
just a absolutely phenomenal [ __ ]
movie it actually made me sad that we
were in final descent that's how good
that goddamn movie is but anyway so I
just know that potheads I'm not making
fun you know if I make fun of some guy
who's a booze bag booze bag [ __ ]
losers sitting around drinking beer all
day on the couch that doesn't mean that
I don't think that anybody should drink
all right
so [ __ ] relax Jesus Christ I thought
you got mellow when you smoke weed
[Music]
anyways let's plow ahead
hey butt-head can you guys basically
just admit that you want weed to be free
just so you can just sit around smoke it
and not have to worry about anybody
hassle and yeah you know they use a
classic hippie word why can't you just
admit that and stop telling me about you
know how the [ __ ] Declaration of
Independence was written on hemp and all
these you know I mean Jesus Christ she
can make a potted plant out of a 40 and
empty 40 ounce I'm not gonna sit there
and act like I don't wish that I want to
drink in public right dude my brain shut
down seven minutes ago I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about I need to
start reading again overrated underrated
for this week everybody all right this
guy said underrated banana pancake damn
I made a simple pancake with bananas in
it and I had some some great real maple
syrup from New Zealand and it was
[ __ ] amazing I couldn't believe how
great it tasted I never was a pancake
guy and when I used to go to I was never
a pancake guy when he used to go to
diners back in Jersey it was delicious
but overrated - banana pancakes all
right I got greedy I thought the first
one was so good I went back and made a
second one man was I wrong I ate it and
felt like a gluttonous Pig I should have
known but I at least for temporarily
temporarily forgot happiness comes in
spurts and too much of anything can be
bad I hate to relate life to a couple of
pancakes but it's true I overdid it and
ruined the great single pancake
experience I ate one and it was great I
ate a second and I felt like [ __ ] yeah
there you go dude dude batter pancake
batter is edible cement that's what it
is all right I told those stories before
for all you struggling comedians out
there you don't want to blow a bunch of
cash on food go down to Denny's or an
IHOP and about 9:30 in the morning get
the
[ __ ] full stack of pancakes and force
I don't know if they make him anymore
with all this talking about nutrition I
don't even think back in the day they
give you five and you just I just like
man versus food I just shoved that she
be sweating by the time you got to the
third one all that syrup and all that
butter and then you'd suck down your
water in the OJ and I swear to God you
weren't hungry again till like 10
o'clock at night so you got to skip at
least one [ __ ] meal you know just a
tip just a tip for you let's wind this
podcast down let's go short and sweet
this week shall we
YouTube videos for this week and I'm
gonna tell you right now and I think
these are arguably the best [ __ ]
YouTube videos the best cluster of
YouTube videos that uh that you guys
have suggested since I've been doing
this topic because you guys have are now
actually going outside the realm of
YouTube and finding some really obscure
[ __ ] so for all of you there listening
at home just go to the mmm podcast calm
and we'll have all of these lined up for
you to watch alright here we go
first youtube video and this one right
here is an instant [ __ ] classic I
absolutely love this guy this YouTube
video is called man is tased
mock's cops and still gets away I want
you guys to watch this because not only
is it [ __ ] hilarious but this guy
really shows why it's so important to
know what your rights are as a citizen
I'm not saying the cops aren't still
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you but just
to watch this guy he's actually stumping
the cops on a certain level because they
can't answer his questions they got him
pinned on the ground and they still go
and sir you're underneath the rest do
you realize you're right yeah you're
aware that you're under arrest and he
goes no he goes what's the charge what
is the charge and they just kept going
sir are you aware that you're under
arrest he's like I don't speak the
language I'm not in your king I'm not a
subject of your kingdom right for the
first minute in 20 seconds this guy's
[ __ ] hilarious then he gets all
religious oh geez and then it gets funny
looks like a freak
and then he just starts singing this
[ __ ] song and they're trying to
handcuff him and he is doing the most
simple [ __ ] move with his elbow
really look to see it the cop keeps
going over the wrists go under the wrist
over the wrists under the wrist and he
just keeps moving his [ __ ] elbow it's
literally a two inch move he's moving it
up two inches and down two inches and
this [ __ ] cop cannot get the goddamn
handcuffs on him and the whole time he's
doing this he's singing this [ __ ]
song he's like a poet or something like
that then they tase him and as they're
tasing him he's standing up and he's
he's presenting his case because his
wife is filming it as he's getting tased
he's standing up going i defending
myself I am just spinning myself from
this unjust hazing and then he runs away
it's one of the greatest YouTube [ __ ]
videos ever
this guy is my [ __ ] hero I love him
alright and let's stick with the arrest
theme this week another one is a funny
arrest and this is black dude getting
arrested for drinking and driving and
this guy is absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
he is adamant that he was not he goes I
have been drinking but I wasn't driving
I said I was banking I wasn't driving
you gotta see this guy I'm sick of him
muffled I don't take no [ __ ]
test and then they and as he was yelling
the lady would be like sir and he just
go yo why am I trying to reenact these
these are all [ __ ] hilarious
and be fair and balanced we got a drunk
black guy now we got a drunk [ __ ]
white dude drunk redneck arrest and this
guy isn't drunk I guess he is drunk but
he's [ __ ] he's one of the angriest he
says the meanest [ __ ] ever the cops are
going to arrest him I'll just give you a
little quick little youtube trailers
they go to arrest the guy they already
got him [ __ ] handcuffed and the cops
go and listen no come on man we don't
want to have we don't want to have to
hurt you guys like I know I don't want
to have to hurt you either break your
[ __ ] neck
I'll [ __ ] I can't make up funny just
go watch them
Oh Silent Night deadly night part 5
watch that movie trailer for those of
weak of stomach do not watch this
reporter [ __ ] herself during interview
she has on white pants too just to warn
you and what is the last one oh the last
one for all the drummer's out there I
had a bunch of musicians specifically
drummers send me all these uh all these
emails this week I had no idea the
amount of musicians and the amount of
drummers in particular who listened to
my podcast everybody got to check out
Stewart Copeland Danny Carrie all these
[ __ ] people actually read something
in Rolling Stone about Phil Collins
today and for as much [ __ ] music as he
made in the 80s like that guy is a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] beast of a drummer
left handed drummer still plays those
concert toms with the no bottom no
bottom heads this guy I'm telling this
not enough if anybody's got a great
YouTube video that just has him just
playing I don't want to hear him soloing
with Chester Thompson it was another
great drama I just want to hear him by
himself that guy is a [ __ ] beast and
the sad thing is he stepped out behind
the kid and it was good in the beginning
and then the end it was just you can't
hurry love since since to do just some
of the worst [ __ ] music ever made
and they're actually actually check out
rolling stone he has this whole article
with it if he's talking about how you
know he became the Antichrist he's
actually confused as to why that
happened so I kind of felt bad for him
as an artist but it's like you know
look back on that music Phil do you
really think that [ __ ] holds up she
sees the hem and a visible touch Jeff oh
oh geez terrible music um anyways so
checked so somebody everybody was
sending me these videos of drummers
telling me all this [ __ ] that I should
check out and this was the this was the
drum video that really stood out for me
two things one this is a video I already
knew about if you guys are into like
drum and bass music or if you're
drummers out there and you wonder where
that [ __ ] music came from there's
this video that explains says video
video explains the world's most under a
most important 6 second drum loop and
it's it's basically this this song from
a sort of obscure I guess R&B group
called the Winston's and they had this
song called Amen brother which was
actually a b-side and it had like this I
don't know what it was it was like I
don't know musically how to say it was
like a [ __ ] two bar drum break that
these uh I don't know if people used to
rap over to what they explained the
whole [ __ ] thing and basically how
DJs took that to bar drum break and
isolated every sound of the recording
every like I don't how to musically like
if you could cut it down to like thirty
second notes they just isolated
everything the sound of the ride cymbal
the sound of the bass drum everything
and the sound of all of it together and
just splice the whole [ __ ] thing up
and then re-edit it in different in a
different order and then sped the whole
[ __ ] thing up created all these new
drum beats and sped the whole [ __ ]
thing up past the point where human
beings could actually play drums at that
point
but what's great about [ __ ] human
beings is I like to believe is that
we're better than [ __ ] machines so
the great drummers of the world figured
out how to [ __ ] play that fast that's
a whole nother thing guys like Jojo
Mayer actually through [ __ ] is these
different techniques to play Moeller
method push poll and all that they
figured out how to [ __ ] play at that
level but this video explains basically
how all that drum and bass [ __ ] kind of
came about and check out Jojo Mayer
it's another drum video we'll have up on
the mmm podcast if you're interested in
that [ __ ] how [ __ ] fast this guy can
play and single bass drum players I got
to show you this [ __ ] video this guy
can get three and four bass drum hits in
a row like girl like doing like that
heel-toe [ __ ] it's [ __ ] unbelievable
it's not [ __ ] believable how this guy
can do that anyways I know I'm boring a
lot of this this is even more [ __ ]
obscure than sports but anyways that all
the drum videos you guys sent me a lot
of them I knew and one this is the one
that I was the least familiar with
because I figure everybody knows Danny
carrying a tool and all those major
bands but this is band called Russian
Circles which I had never heard of and
they have a drummer called Harper Lewis
and there's a there's a YouTube video
called Russian Russian Circles Harper
Lewis live at Wicker Park fest oh seven
and it just starts off with you know he
just this [ __ ] guy if I could play
drums at this guy's level this dude's
basically you know as much as you want
to be the guy hitting [ __ ] 8 million
drums and smashing a gong that's on fire
when it really comes down to it you want
to be able to [ __ ] be this goddamn
badass and still be playing for this
song it's like it's kind of like that
David Grohl thing he's another fake the
drum and that David Grohl did on Queens
of the Stone Age it's like it kind of
reminds me of that it's like he just
it's [ __ ] unreal the whole it's all
there it's all [ __ ] there the
dynamics
the building the excitement plane you
know not getting in the way of anybody
else he's playing with he sees the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I got to download some
of this [ __ ] so if anybody knows what
their best album is Russian Circles
please let me know and I'm downloading
that [ __ ] this week cuz uh I'm [ __ ]
the drummer alone I got I got to listen
to more of their stuff all right
I know I'm babbling on here I will end
with this this week all right a little
bit of advice here listen to this
[ __ ] situation this guy got himself
into alright bill my girlfriend is 10
years older than me oh Jesus
she has two kids who Jesus and has been
married and divorced twice dude what the
[ __ ] I'm 26 Jesus Christ college
graduate
has any of this made any sense to any of
you when anybody else be out there 26
college [ __ ] graduate have a
girlfriend ten years older than you with
two kids who's been married and divorced
twice good god man he goes I consider
myself somewhat intelligent I'm sure you
are but not in this area by that I mean
you should have no problem understanding
this email well yeah I know everybody
trashes me I know I know I'm the worst
when it comes to reading this [ __ ] so
anyways here we go he says four weeks
ago I found text messages to some dude
on my girlfriend's phone
that although innocent enough made it
clear that whoever she was texting was
on more familiar grounds than just some
work colleague or a friend Jesus Christ
dude is there gonna be a happy ending
here I confronted her about it and it
predictably led to a lot of
finger-pointing we went back and forth
and for a few days and aired out our
grievances but it seemed agreeable now
he makes I guess point number 2 - Oh two
more weeks passed by and lo and behold I
find more text messages from the same
[ __ ] guy at first I tell myself okay
maybe she can't break things off with
this dude so quickly Jesus Christ dude
you know sometimes liberal thought is a
is a great thing like let's have a fair
[ __ ] trial for somebody before we
hang them from the nearest tree but then
there's times it's [ __ ] stupid this
is just liberal thought to the I mean
how much of a benefit of the doubt can
you give somebody you know so you go so
I confront her about it and this leads
to another round of finger-pointing at
which point she tells me to pack my [ __ ]
and leave I'll dude I'm gonna tell you
right now before I read the rest of it
that's [ __ ] great you didn't have to
do any dirty work you're out you [ __ ]
out so anyways he goes were separated
for a week when she asked me to come
back and move in dude this chick is a
[ __ ] psycho here we go we talked
about a future together
how sorry she is to have done that to me
etc etc for [ __ ] sakes we even talking
about getting married when things
finally [ __ ] evened out I was full of
piss and vinegar and felt vindicated
vindicated that I was the one wronged in
the whole situation and she was actually
making good by taking responsibility for
what she had done though taking
responsibility would have been [ __ ] FD
do the second you see those weird texts
just get I'm telling you right now just
get out of the relationship
there isn't oh sorry sorry about the did
enough that that's it it's over it's
[ __ ]
but whatever you're 26 I guess you still
haven't learned I was dumb in my 20 so
here we go let's read the rest of this
all was well and good until she didn't
come home this Thursday night November
11th she came in Friday morning with no
explanation no apology no nothing she
asked me to give her some more time but
I decided to cut bait and just get the
[ __ ] out of this situation hang on a
second everybody sorry had to give a
little bit laws break there of course
now I'm wracked with guilt of leaving
the woman I loved and live with for the
past 5 [ __ ] year you got with her
when you were 21 dude she was 31 wait
let's do the math she was 31 you were 21
she was already married twice alright
this chicks a psycho and you know what
that means she's [ __ ] great in bed
you were 21 she [ __ ] devastated you
with [ __ ] her [ __ ] right best
[ __ ] you ever had is now what
happened and next thing you know you
were too [ __ ] too young and dumb
either you fell for her yeah Jesus
Christ he stayed there for five [ __ ]
years
so anyway I guess this chick still
calling him tell him she still wants to
get back together I feel like every time
I sack up and do what I think is best
for me she wants me back
and every time what I do what's best for
us as a couple
she uses that as an opportunity to [ __ ]
with me all over again yes yes you're
absolutely right listen to your gut this
guy see he knows the [ __ ] answers
he's listening to his gut good [ __ ]
man um is this is it just that chicks
can't handle a guy that is emotionally
invested or do I just happen to be
dealing with one of those sociopaths
that doesn't give a [ __ ] what she does
so long as it suits her in the moment
yes there's plenty of [ __ ] good women
that has not plenty good one there's
good women out there all right just like
good good man's hard to find is finding
a good woman is also difficult all right
but no you happen to be dealing with an
absolute [ __ ] sociopath all right she
had a fucked-up childhood something
happened to her she that got touched her
[ __ ] dad took off I don't know she
just got the [ __ ]
she got one of those Bad Brains you know
I'm gonna tell you guys my theory on
that the a brain the B brain and the C
brain the a brain is the genius the B
brain is the don't he's a good [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know fitzy and then the C brain
is your [ __ ] mouth breathing [ __ ] all
right and when it comes to being a
sociopath that's like just uh that's
just like getting an option on the car
all brains come with that option it's
all available like satellite radio you
know you get satellite radio and a
[ __ ] Bentley you can also get it my
[ __ ] Prius all right
so did they make any [ __ ] sense you
got a sociopath with the [ __ ] she
could even have the a brain that's the
sad thing about having a fucked-up
childhood she could actually be a
[ __ ] genius but she's got that
sociopath [ __ ] so tell her to go call
[ __ ] dr. drew all right and you get
the [ __ ] out of the relationship
so anyways he'd say I'd imagine your
degree that I did the right thing
but it always helps to get a little bit
of better perspective on it dude I
totally understand you've been in a
five-year relationship you're
emotionally invested in this [ __ ] so you
know what the right thing to do is but
your emotions keep [ __ ] with you all
right so what you got to know is just
look going through a breakup is painful
all right it's not gonna not be painful
but just because it's painful doesn't
mean that it's not the right thing to do
you are 100 [ __ ] percent doing the
right [ __ ] thing you're 26 year old
years old you're in the prime of your
[ __ ] life all right get out of that
situation okay she's 10 years older than
you by the time you're 29 she's gonna be
hit and [ __ ] menopause all right or
something like that whatever sliding
into it I have no [ __ ] idea what
she's gonna be doing she's gonna be
wearing those mom jeans at that point if
she's not already which I don't think
she is
she's probably that [ __ ] you know
that that anorexic cougar look you know
well they got a varicose vein in between
their [ __ ] you can see their
breastplate Jesus Christ bill stay on
topic yes oh dude just get out of that
hang out with you [ __ ] fellas you
know angle your buddies go out and
[ __ ] have some beers join a gym get
[ __ ] shredded go out start talking
[ __ ] when you're ready but don't go back
to that man you dodged a [ __ ] bullet
the fact that you were with her for five
years and you didn't knock her up and
you got out of it and even after five
years you're only 26 years old you made
the best [ __ ] move you're gonna make
all right and now this is what you need
to do you've been in a relationship for
five years you need to be single for at
least a [ __ ] year and a half and I
don't mean just be single and [ __ ]
booze figure out what the [ __ ] you're
looking for all right and when you meet
a girl if she doesn't have it just walk
a banger and leave you know there's
nothing wrong with having a good [ __ ]
time but do not get sucked into another
[ __ ] relationship because you're
gonna cuz you're gonna have to go
through this [ __ ] again you know we just
sitting there and you know it's [ __ ]
wrong but you don't want to go through
the [ __ ] pain of it you keep coming
back it's a [ __ ] nightmare it's a
[ __ ] nightmare good for you sir
I'm [ __ ] proud of you you did the
right thing you're sort of [ __ ]
wavering cuz you're going through the
emotions you're only 26 you got with him
when you were 21 is probably your first
major [ __ ] breakup so it's acceptable
that you [ __ ] up and went back that
second time but do not go back again and
if any of your [ __ ] friends
to this don't let him do that [ __ ] all
right time to a [ __ ] barstool and
start throwing drinks down his throat
ah that's it that's the Monday morning
podcast for this week anything else
where am I gonna be this week oh this
week I'm gonna be at the the Lisner
theater in Washington DC there's only I
believe under a hundred tickets left I'm
doing a bunch of radio so if you want to
come out please come out I'll be hanging
out afterwards doing a meet-and-greet I
have my brand-new DVD let it go I'll be
signing up taking pictures and all that
type of [ __ ] Saturday night I got two
shows at comics at Foxwoods both shows
are sold out but for those of you who
have tickets I will be showing up with
my DVDs afterwards shaking hands
signing dvds doing all that [ __ ] and
thanks everybody's been coming up to me
after shows telling me how much they've
that they like the the podcast and enjoy
my latest special really means a lot to
me and that's it you guys all have a
great week sorry the podcast was so late
this week and I that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves see
[Music]
you